c'est leur d'adresser ses voeux pour les
élus des communes des yvelines nous
reviendrons régulièrement sur les
différentes cérémonies tout au long du
mois de janvier ce soir nous partons
donc pour magny les hameaux où le maire
s'est exprimé lundi soir que faut-il en
retenir pour en parler catrice du gâteau
bonsoir comment s'est passée cette
cérémonie de voeux c'était la maison de
l'environnement une fois n'est pas
coutume effectivement a besoin d'un
environnement y avait beaucoup de monde
en tout cas hier soir et puis pour les
poêler les voeux du maire du nouveau
maire bertrand ou lyon qui a été élu en
septembre dernier on s'en souvient en
remplacement de jacques lolliot ce qui a
préféré passer la main et jacques
cluzaud qui était en poste depuis 1995
et pour sa première cérémonie de voeux
le nouvel édile s'est exprimé devant un
parterre de ministres de députés on en
aperçoit d'élus de toutes tendances
politiques confondues la bccla il y
avait du beau monde hier soir à la
maison de l'environnement bien au récit
ample robe abbas et leclerc du côté de
l'ump on peut citer valérie pécresse
alors c'est logique ainsi la députée de
la circonscription
je sais la chef de file aussi de l'ump
dans le département il y avait ils
vendent mal de conseiller régional c'est
logique il y avait les xives y est le
maire de voisins-le-bretonneux qui est
donc venu en voisin et puis jean michel
fourgous s'éloigne ouailles n'ont pas
grand voilà c'est le maire ump
d'elancourt et côté psa y avait il y
avait du beau monde pour soutenir donc
le maire socialiste de manille avec
benoît mot d'allemand qui est venu en
tant que ministre jean fitte ma les
députés c'est pas sa circonscription
mais il est venu quand même
elle sent une grande bande conseillère
régionale et responsables du ps dans le
département et puis robert cadalbert le
présente deux communautés
d'agglomération et puis un autre maire
françois de ligne et le maire de huy en
cours alors et bien que pense bertrand
rayons de toutes ses attentions on va
l'écouter
ça fait toujours plaisir voilà tout
simplement
je les avais invité et puis ils sont
venus donc c'est avec grand plaisir que
je les ai accueillis
voilà nouveau maire nouvelle activité
curiosité peut-être oui curiosité sans
doute mais aussi lucidité parce que
magny les hameaux il faut bien le dire
attise les convoitises politique l'ump
espère bien conquérir la ville aux
municipales de mars 2014 et pourquoi pas
faire basculer l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines qui a toujours été
détenues par la gauche alors on va
écouter maintenant sandrina au grand
homme je les dis c'est la chef de file
du ps dans le département et c'est elle
hier soir qui se montrait la plus claire
sur la question sans langue de bois en
l'écoutant on peut aussi gagner des
communes sur la droite dans cette agglo
il ya il encourt en particulier sur
lesquelles on va mettre beaucoup de
moyens donc manie n'est pas un cas
particulier pour nous c'est simplement
une villa comporter mais
le travail qui est fait depuis des
années par jacques lolliot son équipe et
puis par bertrand qui prend la suite
nous assure qu'il aura pas de pas de
difficulté bon travail qui est fait avec
de faux et puis un équilibre qui a été
trouvé dans cette ville
c'était à la fois un soutien amical et
puis politique aussi pour lui dire qu il
peut évidemment compter sur nous tous
oui puis plus quoi dire également de la
présence de benoît hamon son entourage
n'a pas caché que sa présence n'était
pas anodine
il faut montrer que bertrand ou lyon est
légitime pour porter la candidature
socialiste devant les électeurs et le
ministre nous a même fait lui même une
petite confidence supplémentaires en
deçà les confidences des politiques sans
pato de tes fils à écouter bien sûr tout
la fin de cette séquence saint benoît
hamon j'étais très heureux de venir
plus il fait un maire de génération
assez proche de la mienne
tu as plein de sincérité d'émotion
d'ailleurs dans ce qu'il disait parce
que c'est un habitant dit si elle était
enfant ici on est maire aujourd'hui il a
beaucoup d enthousiasme voilà moi c'est
plutôt de ce genre delluc j'ai envie de
soutenir
après évidemment je m'intéresse à ce qui
va se passer à trappes à elancourt à
manille à guyancourt à montigny pourriez
figurer sur la liste de trappes de guy
malandain tu es aussi je n'ai pas encore
discuté guy malandain 6 me le propose on
en discutera mais pour l'instant
n'y a pas encore parlé on en discutera
et un sourire qui en dit long à la fin
de cette réponse benoît hamon attrape un
secret qui on n'en est plus vraiment un
pour beaucoup en dehors de ces deux
camps ump et ps qui se prépare pour les
élections de l'année prochaine que
faut-il retenir d'autres de ses voeux de
bertrand
oui parce qu'on a parlé politique moi
parler quand même le hockey parce que
les voeux des maires évidemment c'est
fait aussi pour ça c'est pour parler des
chantiers on peut citer la salle des
fêtes les travaux qui vont démarrer à la
fin du premier trimestre 2013 ans le
pôle anti les puits de mobilisation
certains dossiers comme jédir un vieux
dossier la réouverture du cv 7 qui
permettait le désenclavement de magny
les hameaux vers montigny le bretonneux
c'est un chemin qui a été fermé il ya
plusieurs années sur fait ça revient
chaque année dans les 22m et si son
innocence est clair à la demande de
l'ancien maire de montigny avait été
fermé est-ce que ça va réouvrir
certainement que oui et puis la
rénovation des logements sociaux du
quartier du buisson ça c'est beaucoup
moins amusant c'est un bras de fer qui
s'engage entre la mairie et l'opievoy
qui n'aurait pour l'instant pas
l'intention de s'impliquer davantage
c'est en tout cas ce petit le maire et
puis il ya un autre dossier important
aux yeux de bertrand au lion est en
écoute c'est le déplacement ou
l'enfouissement de la literie tension
qui traverse le quartier du buisson
depuis sa construction question au sénat
posée par catherine tasca donc le 22
janvier à notre demande et elle pose
cette question dans la question et si tu
es magny les hameaux le cas très précis
du quartier du buisson
j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer benoît
hamon juillet évoqué ce sujet il en
parle à ses collègues au gouvernement
les députés sont au courant tout le
monde est au courant la communauté
d'agglomération est prête sur certains
investissements depuis un moment
donc voilà il faut absolument qu'on
puisse avancer sur ce dossier
la seule raison pour laquelle on n'a pas
pu aboutir il ya quelques années a
priori serait sur le fait que
la zone boisée qui est autour du
quartier est une zone une réserve
naturelle
voilà ce qu'il fallait retenir des voeux
du maire de manier lundi soir et puis en
résumé on peut dire quand même que les
habitants des quartiers où on veut le
voir un leur mère on imagine bien c'est
clair
merci catherineau vous retrouve demain
pour revenir cette fois ci sur les voeux
du maire de guyancourt françois de ligne
et haute technologie à présent pour que
les satellites envoie les bonnes
informations au bon endroit il dispose
de réflecteurs des réflecteurs qui sont
fabriqués dans les yvelines dans les
locaux d'astrium aux mureaux un
reportage d'alice gastines sur des
images de patrick jacques de dixmude
concentration précision et savoir faire
les ingénieurs d'astrium travaillent à
la fabrication de réflecteurs satellite
la filiale aéronautique de ads installé
aux mureaux est l'une des dix
entreprises mondiales qui maîtrise cette
technologie complexe il faut en effet
que ces paraboles de 2,6 mètres de
diamètre installé sur les satellites de
télécommunications renvoi correctement
les données
en d'autres termes les ingénieurs
doivent faire en sorte que l'information
envoyée aux satellites soit redirigée
sur terre à l'endroit voulu ce ne sont
pas des paraboles parfaite ce sont des
surfaces formé avec des bosses des creux
ses formes permettent de d'avoir la
france l'espagne et de ne pas user par
exemple océan atlantique
mais d'abord les canaris par exemple une
fois équipé de réflecteurs 4 en moyenne
le satellite est envoyé en orbite
géostationnaire à 36 mille kilomètres de
la terre par des lanceurs comme ariane 5
fabriquer aussi aux mureaux et à cette
distance les conditions météo sont très
variables
quand on envoie nos matériels ils
peuvent être déformés à cause des
températures
par exemple si on envoie un morceau
d'aluminium dans l'espace
avec eelv à se dilater quand il va
arriver à plus 100 65 degrés et il va te
reste restreindre énormément quand il va
être à moins de 110 degrés pour éviter
cette déformation l'utilisation du
carbone les paraboles sont fabriqués en
matériaux composites pour développer un
réflecteur il faut compter entre 7 et 9
mois depuis le dessin à la réalisation
des essais en passant par la fabrication
70 salariés travaillent dans ce
département et des projets innovants
sont en cours comme des réflecteurs à
double bande de fréquence capable de
renvoyer un plus grand nombre
d'informations